are now played by rimshot toughest out
of five harden for three right and the
a lot whether he's playing TV or safety
in this defense just causing havoc on
the defensive end
for his offensive league with Gerald
Green
[Applause]
[Music]
but the top given suspect detector
finding a good time to get his first
bill gold of this series just kind of
cuts through and finds his spot that
short corner by toxic shot clock at five
[Applause]
[Music]
Tucker back to harden and harden shoots
I find
[Applause]
to you and then waiting to come back to
me hitting on man wide open in the
corner the handles of Chris Paul and
that's the way they play here tonight
Sunday flyers to the point of the Ariza
steps back to the three the beautiful
table movement po-faced man movement
ball movement and it's Gordon knocking
down Paul on the drive of the ball a lot
of passes here through this Houston
Rockets
and because his team gave them
confidence in the first quarter they
played with an even higher level of
course play at a high level with his
future
you know they come in bunches from a
small
Gordon Gordon setback its appalled front
one to five
you drive here my grade
rent out my hundred dollar fine
for three additional
what seemed a maybe candidate
[Applause]
22:14 es5 please
[Music]
[Applause]